we have one more this is Jill Caprica
have a say Jill have a stirring
everybody I'm sorry audience okay hello
Jill
ah nice to meet you nice to meet you
yeah how's it going good I'm impressed
that the pronunciation on my last name
pretty huh burr Kern
you got it it kinda sounds like like a
medieval village I bet you got a crest
you don't know about maybe I have power
I don't know about it all so yeah we're
all secretly every American secretly
waiting for someone with a cloak to be
like your family is special that's why
we love like Jason Bourne like I don't
want to learn kung fu I want to be told
I just got that I already know exactly
you know what I mean takes all the work
out of it that's right Jill hammer Kern
this is my overshare and I will read
yours thank you very much Jill is here
here's our overshare when I was a kid my
dad used to make my siblings and I
salute a painting of John Wayne before
we started our day
yeah
Wow yeah I I wish it wasn't true but
it's completely true yes you can feel
the truth who who would make that help
not a hammer Kern he's gonna be so mad
ah what's he gonna do shoot us why don't
you read mine
alright I'm an honest with my
pornography piece Joe I will lock onto
one person and just really commit to
them feel it allow it
chill thank you so much for playing oh
you can salute that's audience Irish
everybody we'll be right back